this morning President Trump went after
the Muller witch-hunt tweeting quote the
appointment of the special counsel is
totally unconstitutional
despite that we'll play the game because
I unlike the Democrats have nothing have
done nothing wrong
all right here with all the legal
commentary I call him the great one he's
the host of CR TV's Levin TV the host of
life liberty Levin the number one show
on Sunday nights at 10:00 here on fox
news the great one all right the idea
that a president can't be indicted I
want you to deal with that I want you to
deal with the idea of pardons I want you
to because this is your wheelhouse mark
and the idea that the president's done
anything wrong I see you've got your
papers and you are prepared sir go I
number one this indictment issue the
president can't be indicted according to
the United States Department of Justice
the two memos that they put together
this has been the position of the
Department of Justice for almost half a
century mr. Muller is an inferior
employee in terms of the Department of
Justice he works for the Department of
Justice and he must comply with the
policies of the Department of Justice so
we've been putting aside the
constitutional issue he can't defy the
Department of Justice and bring an
indictment
I believe they already understand that
because they watch your show
constitutionally we know he can't either
because of the arguments laid out by a
Republican administration and Democrat
administration in other words you can't
the president the United States
he's the most powerful man in the
federal government and expect him to
have his due process constitutional
rights properly defended at the same
time no president's been indicted and
there's a reason for that no presidents
ever been brought before a federal grand
jury and there's a reason for that
perhaps mr. Muller is the one who is the
tyrant not the president United States
now the appointments clause of the
Constitution President Trump didn't
write that last time I checked the
framers wrote it and it was ratified by
all the states the defect here is not
that every special counsels appointment
is unconstitutional every special
counsels appointment is not
unconstitutional
this special counsel appointment is
unconstitutional because the Deputy
Attorney General mr. Rosenstein hasn't
educated himself about the appointments
clause he does not have the power
to substitute his well for the President
and the Senate the president nominates
principal officers to come to the United
States Senate and the Senate must
confirm assistant attorneys general
assistant a United States Attorney's
assistant secretaries and up the problem
is mr. Rosenstein converged so much
power on to this special counsel no
specific criminal statutes no specific
individuals really and his oversight is
so passive and so limited as he promised
he would keep his hands off of mr.
Muller that he's created an
unconstitutional special counsel and I
and I believe that the president
challenges to that that one day he will
be successful now the pardon power you
know this memo they keep referring to on
Capitol Hill mr. Schumer of all people
it's two and a half pages long page one
page two page three see my exes those
are the irrelevant parts of the memo
that have nothing to do with what's
going on today see the circle that's it
and there's one sentence in this whole
thing under the fundamental rule that no
one may be a judge in his own case it
would seem that the question should be
answered in there negative that is
whether president can harden himself
this is not a legal document this is a
joke do you see all the footnotes here
if there aren't any you see all the case
law here
there isn't any it's a novel question
because no presidents ever been indicted
so why are we even discussing this
pardon power because the Washington
exede with the New York Times one of
their reporters in one of the
highlighted sections of their phony
article based on the leaked letter puts
in there is the president saying that he
can pardon himself of course the
president could pardon himself here's
the language in the Constitution Article
2 section 2 the president has the power
to grant reprieves and pardons for
offenses against the United States
excepting cases of impeachment do you
hear anything there it says except in
the case of the president all these
protections are built into our
Constitution to protect our Constitution
to protect the president from the mob
from the media from the Democrats that
are a mob today they're here to protect
him it's not the president who's
violating the Constitution it's the
media
what the Constitution violated it's the
Democrats who want the Constitution
violated it's Muller and his merry band
of Democrat prosecutors who are tipping
around a constitutional confrontation as
I've said here every time I've been on
your show Shawn the Constitution is the
president's friend and I'm speaking
rather slowly so even Joe Scarborough
can comprehend what I'm saying or even
Chris Cuomo can comprehend what I'm
saying the president is in this position
because of what mr. Rosenstein did he
created an unconstitutional monster who
is threatening to bring the president in
front of a federal grand jury which is
unconstitutional has never been done
with this notion of obstruction of
justice when he exercises his
prerogatives as president because they
want to indict him which has never been
done the only way to remove a present in
the United States is the old-fashioned
way through the Senate and that's it and
so it's not the president who is the
thug it's mr. Muller who's the thug it's
not the president who's the incompetent
it's mr. Rosenstein who's the
incompetent
and they could mock the president his
attorneys all they want if they show up
in the Supreme Court I'm bettin that the
president and his attorneys win and you
are saying the Constitution is on the
president's side and he needs to take it
in his attorneys need to take it all the
way last point I am saying whether it's
the appointments clause or the pardon
power or the issue of indicted a
president United States he is right on
on his tweets and he's making the people
who are criticizing him look like fools
I would say this and I've said it before
where the hell is the United States
Congress the Republicans control it they
need to hold hearings they need to ask
mr. Rosenstein why he didn't recuse
himself since he recommended that Comey
be fired they need to ask mr. Muller
about those memos out of the Justice
Department they need to ask mr. Muller
what authority has to drag a president
in front of a federal grand jury or
subpoena him what authority does he have
to even contemplate in denial president
and how is it that he hasn't violated
the appointments clause of the
Constitution Congress has a role for
crying out loud in their article 1 they
were created first in the Constitution
they don't have to sit back and watch
all this they need to get involved in it
all right that's why I call you the
great one mark so important we get this
right
with where our constitutional republic
depends on it you could see them Sunday
nights don't miss it watch Mike Mark
show life liberty Levin every Sunday
number one show on cable right here on
Fox